say the original price of an item is
like $70 right and the discount is 30%
so they say for example are having a
sale it's 30% off and you want to find
out what's the new price what's that
sale price right well there's two
different ways to do this one way to do
this is you can say well let me figure
out what I'm going to save so I'm going
to take the $70 I'm going to multiply by
30% but I'm going to convert this into a
decimal by moving that decimal point two
places to the left
so that's going to be 0.3 zero and if we
multiply those together we can use a
calculator you can do this by hand
you're just going to multiply those
together 70 times 0.3 0.2 $21 so what
that means is that you're saving $21
right but that means you're gonna have
to take away the $21 from 70 so 70 minus
21 equals how much $49 right so that's
going to be your new price now that's
one method I'm going to show you a
quicker method now and this quicker
method is instead of focusing on what
you're saving focus on what you're
paying so what percentage would you be
paying if it's 30% discounted or 30% off
well you'd be paying 70 percent right so
what you can do is you can jump right to
$70 and we're gonna multiply that by 70
percent which 70 percent as a decimal is
0.7 zero I just move the decimal two
places to the left
so now all we have to do is multiply 70
times 0.7 0.3 got in method one above
the only difference here is a little bit
quicker we did it in one step because we
focused on what we're paying and we
figured out what that percentage was by
taking a hundred percent minus 30
percent okay let's look at another
example see if you can do this one on
your own
if you want you can pause the video and
go ahead and then check it back with me
here so let's see so number two we've
got the original price of an item is
$400 the discount is 40 percent so it's
like 40% off and now we want to find out
what the new prices so you can use
either method I'll do both methods for
this one but let's see the next one I'll
just pick one of the methods so here are
the discounts 40 percent so let's see
where we're gonna save so we're gonna
take $400 we're gonna multiply by 40
percent which is point four zero as a
decimal okay so move that decimal two
places to the
and if we do that you can do that by
hand or you can do it on a calculator
we're getting a hundred and sixty
dollars right so that means that you're
going to be saving 160 dollars so we
have to take the four hundred minus 160
which means that you're gonna pay the
new price of two hundred and forty
dollars now a method number two let's
just say instead of taking 40% off let's
just say that we're gonna focus on what
you're gonna pay which is sixty percent
right so we're just gonna take the four
hundred dollars we're gonna multiply by
sixty percent which is point six zero
and if you do that on a calculator
you're gonna get 240 or you can do it by
hand okay so that's a number two so
let's jump in at number three I'm just
gonna pick one of the methods for this
one so here it's a little bit more
challenging we don't know what the
original price is we knew we know what
the new price is and we know what the
discount is so how do we solve a problem
like this well there's a couple
different ways to do it I'm gonna write
an equation so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna say hmm that original price let's
call that axe since we don't know what
it is now it's being discounted by 25
percent but that means you're actually
gonna pay 75 percent right 75 percent is
really 0.75 as a decimal
and the answer to that is going to be
the new price $180 so just to go over
that real quick again the starting price
which we don't know x times the amount
that you're going to pay equals a new
price so now all we have to do to solve
for X is to divide both sides by 0.75
see how these are multiplied together
we're doing the inverse which is to
multiply both sides and let's just go to
the calculator let's see what that is
180 divided by 0.75 okay we're getting
240 dollars and you got it now if you
want to check your work and you of
course can you just have to take 240
dollars times 0.25 okay and that's gonna
be how much that you're saving subtract
that from the 240 and you get 180 okay
let's do another example so number 4
we've got the original prices 620
dollars but now we don't know what the
discount is we don't know that percent
discount and we know the new price is
434 dollars so what do you think for
this one how can we approach this one
well let's go ahead and write an
equation so we're gonna start off with
the 620 dollars and we're gonna multiply
by like let's just say ax
okay and that's gonna give us the new
price $434 now this X percent the way
I've set this up this is going to be the
percentage that you pay right so you're
paying that percent of the original
price and that's your new price so keep
that in mind so now we're going to do is
we're in a divide both sides by 620 okay
and now we're left with X okay and let's
see what that comes out to you so we've
got 434 divided by 620 it's coming out
to 0.7 0.7 0 as a percentage we have to
move that decimal two places to the
right that's 70% now that means you're
paying 70% but what's the discount 30%
right so that's gonna be our discount
okay now we've got one additional
problem if you want I called this bonus
number one go ahead and see if you can
do this on your own put the answer in
the comment section below if you want
compare with other viewers to see if
you're on the right track and this is a
good one for you so the original price
we don't know the discount percentage is
4% so 4% off and the new price is 80
dollars and 64 cents so go ahead and try
that one on your own I'm gonna wipe the
whiteboard down real quick and we're
gonna do the percent markup problems
next okay now we're going to talk about
percent markup so let's go through some
examples together I'll show you the two
different methods for solving these
types of problems so let's say your
original amount is $28 and then the
mark-up is 80% and you want to find out
what the new price is gonna be so say
for example a store you know they're
getting in merchandise they're marking
it up selling it to the customer for
additional amount so they can make a
profit right so there's two different
ways to do this the first way is you
would take the $28 okay that you're
starting with and you would multiply by
80% as a decimal which is 0.8 zero you
want to move that decimal point two
places to the left and let's see what
that comes out to so we're gonna find
out the additional amount that they're
gonna charge the customer so that's 28
times point eight zero which comes out
to twenty two dollars and forty cents
now the thing is the $22.40 this is the
additional amount we have to add that to
the original amount so I'm going to add
the 20
eight dollars and so now you can see
we're getting how much this is fifty
dollars and forty cents okay now there's
another way to do this problem the other
way to do it is if they're marking it up
by 80% the customer is actually paying
one hundred and eighty percent a hundred
percents the original amount plus an
additional eighty percent so when you
think of a hundred and eighty percent
that's actually one point eight zero I
just move that decimal point two places
to the left now all we have to do is
take the original amount the twenty
eight dollars times the hundred and
eighty percent and let's verify that we
get the same answer so you can do this
on your calculator with me if you want
times one point eight zero again we get
fifty dollars and forty cents okay let's
go to the next example so each one of
these problems is a little bit different
than the previous one so number two
we've got the original amounts eighty
the new amount is a hundred and forty
but we're wondering what is that markup
percentage okay so what we can do again
two different methods one method is you
can see that this is actually increasing
in price by sixty dollars so we'd say
eighty dollars the original amount times
the percent okay mark up equals the
additional amount that they're charging
the customer which is an additional
sixty dollars so if we go to the
calculator here I'm going to divide both
sides by eighty to get the variable by
itself so 60 divided by eighty you can
see we're getting 0.75 so again I'm
dividing both sides by eighty we're
getting 0.75 but you see how this is a
percentage we want to move that decimal
point two places to the right to convert
it back into a percentage so this is
actually a seventy five percent markup
now the other way to do this problem and
this is the way that I actually like to
do it is I take the eighty dollars and I
say eighty times what so I'll just say
ax equals the new amount one hundred
forty dollars so let's go ahead and do
that I'm gonna divide both sides by 80
to get X by itself so we've got 140/80
you can see we're getting 1.75 so x
equals 1.75 but if I move this decimal
point two places to the right we're
getting a hundred and seventy five
percent but a hundred percent means the
original amount plus an additional 75
percent so you can see that's at our
actual markup percentage
seventy-five percent so let's go to
example number three now now this one's
a little bit different than the first
two here we're trying to find the
original amount
we know the mark-up percentage is thirty
percent and we know the new amount which
is 104 okay so how would you solve that
one well I'm going to use method number
two over here and I'm going to do this I
like this I'm gonna say ax is the
original amount times not thirty percent
but a hundred and thirty percent because
I want to figure out the mark-up plus
the original to get the new amount which
equals a hundred and four so now if we
divide both sides by a hundred and
thirty percent or one point three zero
we're going to get that original amount
so let's go ahead and do that 104
divided by one point three zero we're
getting eighty and that's our